another Democrat is ready to challenge
President Trump in 2020 together America
we will rise on Cory Booker and I'm
running for president of the United
States of America senator Cory Booker
sent that message to supporters this
morning the New Jersey New Jersey
senator is the fifth official candidate
while three others have formed
exploratory committees ed O'Keefe is on
Capitol Hill and it's getting crowded
out there good morning sure is John
senator Booker has long been seen as a
potential Democratic presidential
candidate he is New Jersey's junior
senator and the 49 year old has served
here in the Senate since 2013 before
that he had served as mayor of Newark
for more than seven years
Booker's campaign is expected to focus
on addressing wealth inequality and
especially on the idea of restoring a
sense of unity in the country he spent
much of the past year road-testing that
message on the campaign trail for fellow
Democrats and during visits to early
primary States on Capitol Hill Booker
has at times tried unifying the place by
working with Republicans like Rand Paul
on criminal justice reform when he's
also been a strongly partisan Democrat
notably during the confirmation hearings
for Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh Booker is scheduled to head to
Iowa next weekend for campaign stops
next weekend is also when Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren tells us she
will formally kick off her campaign John
all right ed O'Keefe thanks so much head